all right we are following the continued
meltdown in mega world over the trump
fbi raid this started monday night
during our live coverage we watched sean
hannity absolutely lose it in some
breathless 11-minute monologue about
who even knows what benghazi and obama
and due process who knows what he was
talking about this continued yesterday
and we're going to look at some examples
and you
what's notable about these is obviously
they're running interference for trump
now there's a couple things that can be
going on some of these folks may
themselves be worried
that they could be implicated in the
materials found at mar-a-lago it's
conceivable
the second part of this is look at how
quickly they are willing to abandon
their supposed principles
as soon as they don't like the way
things are going i'm going to give you
one example here here is charlie kirk
seen as a hero to young conservatives
around the country and all this
different stuff
he says well
if trump was raided
then they should raid black lives matter
planned parenthood and george soros
why would you raid those things that
doesn't make any sense charlie well
let's see if he explains it
and i'm going to say this plainly and
bluntly raids must be met with raids
they raid donald trump's home well why
don't you go raid blm for burning down a
billion dollars with a property in the
summer of 2020. so
each of those property crimes
is being and has been investigated
and you don't need a raid
if you don't believe that there is
evidence of a crime
at a location like sometimes you would
just arrest somebody you know you don't
necessarily always need a raid in lots
of types of alleged crimes but why would
you start raiding people it doesn't make
sense charlie they raped donald trump
why don't you go raid planned parenthood
for all of their let's just say
very revealing crimes that was revealed
five or six years ago on camera yeah uh
charlie kirk is referring to
a sort of staged sting operation
that was then used to make false claims
about planned parenthood
and there is no reason that today you
would start raiding planned parenthood
because a legal search warrant was
executed at donald trump's home
they raid donald trump why does george
soros get away with everything he's
doing funding attorney general's offices
well funding attorney general's offices
what crime has taken place charlie
and also
why do they always bring george soros
into this these conspiracy theorists
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
bish
yeah um george soros charlie it's a
little bit too on the nose so all of a
sudden due process going out the window
just start raiding everybody
then there's the planted evidence
conspiracy theory we already did a
segment on that earlier in the show but
just to be thorough i am going to play
it again so that we included in this
clip there are 10 of these i could play
here's just one this is the planted
evidence conspiracy theory and i won't
subject you to all of it let's just
listen to a little bit of it by 20 or 30
points yes uh and she's part of this i
mean she is part of the effort to turn
the system
into a basically a tyrannical
anti-conservative anti-republican
constant violation of the law which is
what the january six committees you have
a fake committee being covered by the
fake news with a fake fbi uh which by
the way you'll notice they didn't allow
anybody on the trump side into
mar-a-lago so we have no idea whether or
not they planted evidence yes that's
exactly right and and newt i have a
couple thoughts number one i wish i
trusted our law enforcement you need
some form of law enforcement to have a
civil society but i'm right with you i
say oh they're planting evidence how
how disappointing of a place we are in
our country where our immediate reaction
is that our own
law enforcement agency might be planning
evidence against a former president
there is no such evidence there is no
reason to believe that they are planting
evidence there is simply no reason to
believe that and then here's another
talking point that a lot of them are now
uh stuck to and that talking point is
if the fbi can do this to trump they
could do this to anyone no one is safe
this is a very dumb
talking point and i'll tell you why in a
moment here's tennessee republican
senator marsha blackburn using this one
i think that there are a lot of
questions that we justifiably have and
we want answers because if the fbi can
do this to president donald trump they
can do it to you and the american people
know that that is such a silly talking
point what does it mean
if they can do it to trump they can do
it to you
is a president our vips are wealthy
socialites the elites whatever term you
want to use
the bilderbergs no i'm not doing the
jones thing um
are should they be exempt
should they get special treatment and
also we know it can happen to all of us
it happens to all of us all the time
that's the whole point the point is it
doesn't happen to these people at the
top echelons of society that's why it
could happen to you if it happens to
trump we know it could happen to us
marsha it happens to us all the time
the question is will anybody of
significant power actually be held
accountable so
brain worms a major major problem with a
lot of these uh
right wing conspiracy theories
and maybe the most brain wormy of them
all
is the trump assassination plot
conspiracy theory it's so wacky i want
to separate it and talk about it now in
its own right
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below